okay
Okay
the third spur is very hard to get hold
of
and you know to uh the third square is
very hard to do
I was saying you are only I think
yesterday
it should be
straight up
over the head because the intention is
to take in the Universal key this is
like a funnel
and the and the key is pouring down into
our head
this is you know the Japanese uh belief
but
most people they try and get all these
points points correct and then they go
and drop it out to the side
and so the enemy can see exactly where
their sword is or they get here
and then they turn their body like that
so it's like it's difficult I've got the
sword in the right place now the body's
showing all this
the third one that I I see quite regular
is as they drop it
they sort of go forward like that
so to me they're becoming the aggressor
because they're becoming the enemy
so I just prefer to teach
show that
teach
the first movie
the second suburbs
the third surprise
or if I do the first
three or should I do the second
so I I hit the same
spot
first movie
seconds of early
I'll do the third story
so I'm not so interested in
because it's my body that I'm interested
in developing it's we do the weapons to
develop our taijitsu
and if we start making it complicated
this is the first
this is the second
because we think about stepping back it
means this gets a bit a little bit late
sometimes we do that we step in back
while we're lifting this
so we do that it's like pulling a fish
out of the sea
since we do that
if you think of the first degree
first of all the
second super early but notice my body is
up one
so when you do the third super early the
body stays where it is
back to the seconds of Brewery
back to the first
complete
so we make a pattern that our body can
remember
what one am I doing oh yeah
so I mean you can just quickly switch
because you've only got switched the
second half
as I do in the second or third I don't
know because I'm in The Cutting position
of the second
foreign
it's easy because they all feel the same
apart from
the small piece at the end
if you break them down as I say if you
break them down you get
ah this is the first sometimes
you'll get this for the second
and then you do this
so the timing is wrong but sometimes
you'll get this for the third because
this is the right way of doing it but
then you'll get this
or you'll get
this
yeah
so they're about the three problems that
I've experienced over the years of
teaching
so I'd like you to
okay
I thought you just sort of explore that
explore the feeling hey that they
foreign
because they're starting to all become
the same from the first part and then
when you get to
hey
choose a suburbi once you get to
him
I'll do a second
and try not to let me see the space
try not to let me see
your challenge try to let them ah try to
let me see
hey you do it smoothly